[Music]
I certainly hope you dance as well as
you dress
there's only one way to find out
[Music]
you and I we're not so different agent
Argyle
little help hold on
[Music]
the book is phenomenal sweetie but
what happens next it's called a
cliffhanger mother Ellie it's called a
cop-out
[Music]
whoa hey there's a cat in there
oh my God you're Ellie freaking Conway
oh yeah what is it you do Espionage
would you sign my book
here we go
I love this book
come on
[Music]
who are these people real life spies why
would they care about me because you're
a goddamn fortune teller really
when you wrote in your new book actually
happened and you kicked the Hornet's
Nest you didn't even know existed I made
some really big trouble mom
oh so now you're experimenting with
drugs I want all assets on them now I
need her to write the next chapter
God I hate that cat
[Music]
it's time for you to meet the real agent
Argyle
oh my God oh my God oh my gosh
[Music]
foreign
no
you gotta be a good person to go to
heaven
so we're the same
we can't go to heaven because they're
not good
and I'm not a person
[Music]
thank you
they're coming to get me
[Music]
I'm like a bodyguard I'm getting you out
of this
[Applause]
[Music]
take care of her
I promise
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
on September 22nd
time for music We heard you this is
gonna be fun
and clear
please make Expendables for rated R
there better be violence and lots of it
I want all the blood and guts it
first things first holy
my mind is full of these brutal
fantasies fantasies
[Music]
I will now become a headless reality
that's a great idea
well I don't play no more
you're my kill me you're welcome
now that's what I'm talking about
good to be back
[Music]
enjoy the show
Expendables definitely
rated R
in theaters September 22nd
do you know that feeling when you're
doing exactly what you're put on the
earth to do the one where it's like
everything inside you is moving together
in harmony with the universe
me neither
but you know one can hope right
wave the mommy because she'll hate me
even more than she already does if you
don't icing her call you saying that
becoming a lawyer would only crush your
soul yeah it is I'm running a business
right now that business is getting a
journalist in and out of paledonia
no no it's a one-off no no and no it was
a journalist I have resigned my position
here Madison 20 grand says you are
welcome president finaga so nice to meet
you
you must take a selfie um
you approved
oh what the hell just happened you're
one man's security detail happen he's a
human I'm not the president of a country
in the middle of a coup this is the
scoop of a lifetime you got to be alive
to have a scoop for a lifetime you never
should have come let's go you can't just
leave him
[Music]
run run
I'm just doing my job
what
[Music]
you're still excited to cover a coup
less unless honestly man
oh my God
Color Me impressed Mr petite
petite at all
[Music]
four years ago I was basically
unemployed
Wanderer with no home
but now I'm a husband and a father
and I wouldn't have it any other way
my job was a little less stressful than
yours
oh yeah I finally got a job I'm the king
of Atlantis
half a billion people from every known
species in the sea
the sea call this place home
that doesn't mean they all like me
I'm gonna kill Aquaman and destroy
everything he holds dear
I'm gonna murder his family
burn his
cute ass
he must be stopped for a global meltdown
is imminent
I think I know someone might go to help
us
fool you look rough
good job little brother high five do not
call me brother
I cannot believe you let this happen
yeah well I hate this job true king
built Bridges right
build Bridges
Amanda is different
now stronger than before
it's the black Trident
doing King outland's time there were
Seven Kingdoms
was the curse upon them all
spreading
he means to end the bottom line
[Music]
I don't know if I said but we can't
leave our children a world without hope
you're not as bad at this as you think
the Seven Kingdoms will follow
[Music]
[Applause]
my son never show Mercy
we
are predators
boys your mother is dead
she died because you sent her away she
was weak sick in her mind
you'll know my business yes
power is about strength if you show
weakness you will give our enemies an
opening
[Applause]
shot
he's weak like his mother leave him
what happened that day
I stared death in the face and for the
first time I saw my true self
tell me about this Hunter
they say he uses a connection with
animals to track his prey
once you're on his list
there's only one way off the six of us
and only one of you there's six of you
now
[Music]
why do you hunt my father puts evil into
the world
I take it out
[Music]
I think you're some kind of Honor you
were exactly like our father just
another man hunting for a trophy
the murderers
isn't that what he taught us
you don't get to do that to me anymore
Mr tagline
Mr tackling
where's Mr tagley oh you're standing in
him
you're a goddamn lunatic oh you just
figured that out now
there is an animal I need to wind up
fast don't you want to know why they
call me the rhino
let's just know
after everything you've seen out there
in the world
what are the Hunger Games for
[Music]
coming
The Hunger Games are to punish the
districts us tributes don't have a
choice
Your Role is to turn these children into
spectacles not survivors
we're live
smile it's why we have teeth
cared about me that I was still of value
welcome to the Capitol you look like you
shouldn't be here I shouldn't but I'm
your Mentor a rebel
I am gonna get you out of here if you
want to protect people
and it's essential to accept what human
beings are
what it takes to control them
views that famous snow charm
you seem like a good man coylina snow I
have seen what war does to people
filled with the terror becoming prey see
how quickly we become predator
I want my enemies to see a rainbow of
Destruction
engulfing the world
good luck with that poor little Songbird
where is she
it's mystery and Mysteries have a way of
driving people
snow let me ask you one final time what
are the Hunger Games for
[Music]
it's the things we love most and destroy
us
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
killed Danvers prodigal child of the
Milky Way
Nick Fury my favorite one-eyed man of
intrigue how goes it out there I am cold
No Air
space
[Applause]
[Music]
you took everything from me
and now I'm returning the favor
laughs
what is happening to me
[Music]
she's entangled our light-based powers
so we switch places whenever we use them
Theory
you can absorb light
I can see it and Kamala who's Kamala hi
she can turn light into physical matter
which I have never heard of I could
totally show you
foreign
[Music]
she's targeting every planet we call
home
I would never choose to bring anybody
into this
you are not the only thing standing
between this and the universe
[Music]
further faster
thank you
[Music]
the good kitty cause
I can't can you I got it
[Music]
ETA five minutes to the war zone we must
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
Jonas we need your help
we're detecting increased aquatic
activity 25 000 feet deep in the trench
it's an ancient ecosystem Untouched by
man whatever is down there is trying to
make its way to the surface
this is a bad idea just a little bit
[Music]
Jonas
we've got company
that's the biggest night I've ever seen
biggest bag anyone's ever seen
that's the apex predator
everybody make it to the station
three massive exit who knows what else
have escaped the breach
I just hope it goes better than last
time
what happened last time
you don't want to know
[Applause]
we've never seen this before they hunted
it back
oh
you can relax this place is Meg proof
Majoris was always afraid of this but I
was also thinking
hello
[Music]
oh barracuda
this Barbarian blood that drives your
heart but they say look at you and those
are full of hope
they must not find their savior they
believe that a woman warrior will
somehow be their salvation
Rome cannot and will not recognize you
as Queen
[Music]
all people ask the gods of the land to
provide us a leader and now they have
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
reinforcements that we cannot defeat
I cannot lose you know that
on this spot we must conquer oh die
you're all the very best in the world of
what you do
I want you to know that this isn't your
typical contract
it's more like a
competition to kill me king of killers
or I can guarantee I will kill you
we're still on for tonight right 8 p.m
at the coal train our anniversary is
tomorrow
Marcus
[Music]
where are you baby I'll find out who did
this
you're invited to eliminate the world's
greatest assassin so who's the client
dracos I'm in were they sending in
welcome to Japan you set all this up I'm
your employer I work alone
nobody leaves until the game is finished
and we fight hard and Die With Honor
that's what I'm talking about he set
this whole thing up we have to change
the rules on that the only way we
survive this is if we work together all
of us versus you
does that sound
[Applause]
told you I was competitively
[Music]
[Applause]
you sure you want a piece of that
who's next
no doubt you've seen the chaos in the
streets
we must make an example of our France
will fall
what would you do with this assignment
of defense was transferred to you
[Applause]
I promise you brilliant successes
[Music]
I love the French Victory too long
what is your name Napoleon as the course
of my life just changed Napoleon
I'm destined for greatness
but I was in power only see me as a
sword
I suggest you take the throne as a king
shall we vote
[Applause]
this Burning has held the world of
Hostage with his egotism and his lack of
simple good manners
you think you've cried
that is nothing without me
all of Europe his United forces against
me what's the outcome of this if you
don't succeed
Your Majesty we are discovered good
first two metal I make a mistake
I simply never do
gentlemen I've got good news lady death
is alive I know we thought she was dead
sir I sent her on a mission to terminate
Ivan bubalo the cultivator his regime is
quickly gaining the political and
territorial foothold to cause serious
unrest in the region
gentlemen your mission is to extract LED
and finish what she started let's get to
work let's go the CIA can't officially
be involved that's where we come in
yeah she's fine what about the girl
she's working for the United States
Wonder
at any cost
of the there's a tracking device on you
don't lost contact with my team I need
help finding them assuming they're still
alive
let's go I don't even know how to use
this
do this
[Music]
foreign
thank you